digamos que tenemos una bolsa y en dicha
bolsa voy a poner algunos cubos verdes y
en particular van a ser 8 cubos verdes y
también pondré algunas esferas en dicha
bolsa las cuales van a ser 9 esferas 9
esferas verdes y también pondré algunos
cubos amarillos digamos que van a ser
cinco cubos amarillos y también algunas
esferas otras esferas de color amarillo
en dicha bolsa entonces aquí tenemos
siete esferas amarillas y quizás sea un
error que haya puesto en dicha bolsa
muchas más esferas pero bueno en
realidad vamos a ver qué pasa son un
poco más de esferas pero pensemos en
este vídeo
cuál es la probabilidad de obtener
diferentes tipos de objetos entonces por
ejemplo cuál es la probabilidad de
obtener o sacar un cubo un cubo de
cualquier color y la forma de pensarlo o
mejor dicho una de las maneras de
pensarlo es cuáles son todas las
equivalentes probabilidades de que saque
este cubo de la bolsa y bien son 8 + 9
17 y luego 17 522 luego 22 + 7 son 29
por lo que hay 29 objetos son 29 objetos
en la bolsa así que vamos a ver cuáles
son las posibles formas de que cumplan
esta condición entonces el total de
posibilidades son 29 y este diagrama va
a representar todas las posibilidades de
las difi los diferentes tipos de objetos
y entonces de estas 29 posibilidades
tenemos 8 cubos verdes y tenemos cinco
cubos amarillos por lo que en total son
13 cubos entonces déjame dibujar
y los 13 cubos entonces son 13 cubos
este círculo estará representando los es
algo así entonces esto de aquí va a ser
un conjunto de puros cubos esta área es
lo que está representando y es pero está
haciendo un poco exacto entonces estoy
aproximando nuestros 13 cubos en esta
área que representa el conjunto de cubos
entonces la probabilidad de obtener un
cubo va a ser el número de eventos que
cumplen nuestro criterio que son 13
posibles sobre el total que son 29
posibilidades entonces esta es la
probabilidad de los cubos ahora pensemos
en la probabilidad de sacar un objeto
amarillo y puede ser un cubo o una
esfera y una vez más cuáles de estos
casos cumplen nuestras condiciones de
aquí y tenemos 57 que es 12 y son 12
objetos color amarillo en la bolsa
entonces de las 29 posibilidades aunque
no sean del mismo color pero es el total
de posibilidades
probables de los cuales 12 van a cumplir
nuestro criterio entonces vamos a
dibujar los 12 color amarillo por aquí y
esto es mi mejor intento y digamos que
es el conjunto de mis objetos amarillos
que son 12 y los dos se cumplen
nuestra condición entonces la
probabilidad es 12 29 ambos y en el
anterior cumplen 13 de 29 y ahora este
caso son 12 de 29 para objetos amarillos
ahora digamos algo un poco más
interesante que cuál será la
probabilidad de obtener cubos amarillos
y entonces ahora son cubos pero hay que
tener cuidado con el color es un color
amarillo y cuál es la probabilidad de
obtener cubos amarillos y la
probabilidad puede ser que sea uno de
los cinco cubos amarillos que hay sobre
29 posibilidades que son
equivalentemente probables entonces son
29 posibilidades y donde éstos 29
objetos 5 de ellos
con cubos amarillos por lo que dicha
probabilidad son 529 a vos y una forma
de ver esto en nuestro diagrama de ven
que dibuje es sobre dicho diagrama hay
diferentes formas de visualizarlo
entonces algo interesante es cuando
empiezas a pensarlo en donde se van a
interceptar o empalmar los conjuntos y
es donde esto se va a cumplir entonces
aquí estamos hablando de los elementos
de los conjuntos amarillos por lo que
estos conjuntos también van a ir dentro
de los amarillos pero cubos amarillos
así que esta área de aquí que se empalma
con estos dos conjuntos es el área que
representa las caras donde las cosas
donde ambos son amarillos y cubos pues
está dentro de ambos círculos así que
ahora vamos a quizás probablemente sea
el ejemplo más interesante vamos a
pensar cuál es la probabilidad la
probabilidad de obtener un objeto
amarillo o un cubo puede ser un cubo de
cualquier color
un cubo de cualquier color o algo
amarillo y en el denominador sabemos una
vez más que va a ir el 29 pues son todas
las posibles los posibles resultados
igualmente probables que están en la
bolsa pero cuáles son las posibilidades
que cumplen dichas condiciones y bien
una forma de pensarlo es decir bueno
pues son dos objetos que cumplen la
condición de ser cubos amarillos que
están en el lugar de círculos de aquí
que son las doce cosas que cumplen con
la condición de objetos amarillos por lo
que esto de aquí será 12 y es el número
de amarillos pero luego no olvidemos
visualizar que dentro de estos 12
objetos ya están los cinco cubos
amarillos por lo que habría que restar
los de nuestras posibles partes de los
dos objetos amarillos entonces nos
quedaría un total de siete objetos
amarillos y luego tenemos un total de 13
cubos pero también de es dentro de esos
13 ya estaríamos recortando los 5
que son amarillos y además son cubos no
entonces sería sumar 12 13 que sería el
número de amarillos más el número de
cubos sin olvidar a restar estos cinco
cubos que son cubos y además amarillos
el número de cubos amarillos entonces
para no estar contando como doble vez
estos cubos habría que arrestarlos y
otra forma de pensarlo es simplemente
haciendo desde un principio este 13
menos 5 que nos da 8 + 12 igual a 20 sí
creo que es algo más nos y 13 - los
cinco cubos de la intersección nos da 8
+ 12 es igual a 20 y si así sería como
obtendrías dicha probabilidad que serían
20 29 a vos o bien 12 más 13 son 25
menos los cinco también son 20 29 a vos
y es lo más interesante aquí inclusive
que la respuesta de dicha probabilidad
quizás lo que te va a llamar más la
atención será la
en cómo expresar estos términos en
formas de otra probabilidad o más bien
como figurar nos lo un poco más claro en
el vídeo a lo que voy es lo siguiente
tenemos 1229 abós que son la
probabilidad de sacar amarillos más 13
29 ambos que son la probabilidad de
cubos que hay dentro de la bolsa menos
529 abós que es la intersección donde es
la probabilidad de que sean amarillos
perdón por poner esto de amarillos con
verde entonces lo voy a poner de color
amarillo para respetarlo y aquí sería
menos la probabilidad de amarillos de
objetos amarillos y cubos cubos
amarillos objetos amarillos y además
sean cubos entonces esto de aquí es
simplemente estar jugando con las
probabilidades de diferentes formas pero
quise hacerlo de esta manera porque
estoy generalizando todo si te das
cuenta estoy sumando la probabilidad de
que sean objetos amarillos
la prioridad de que sean objetos cubos
menos la intersección de ambos entonces
vamos a verlo de esta forma digamos que
tenemos un conjunto de elementos de un
conjunto a elementos de un conjunto b
entonces vamos a ver cuál es la
probabilidad de a o b entonces es la
probabilidad de que pase el elemento del
conjunto a más la probabilidad de que
pase el elemento del conjunto b menos la
intersección menos la probabilidad de
que pase el elemento a del conjunto a y
la probabilidad de que pase el elemento
del conjunto b y esto es realmente útil
es un resultado que creo que algunas
veces es llamado como la regla de la
suma pero en lo que sí quiero que te
pongas atención es que esta regla es
demasiado común pues la razón del por
qué no puedes simplemente sumar estas
dos posibilidades o estas dos
probabilidades es porque deben haber
elementos traslapados o que son
elementos de ambos conjuntos y si
simplemente sumas ambos
estarías contando doble vez lo que se
intersecta lo cual ya hemos visto en
este vídeo por lo que tenemos que restar
los objetos que se intersectan en ambos
para no tener una doble una doble cuenta
de dichos elementos y otra idea de ver
esto algunas veces es que estas
probabilidades no se intersectan por lo
que digamos que este es el conjunto de
todas las posibilidades del conjunto a y
luego por acá tenemos todas las
posibilidades o las condiciones del
conjunto b y aquí en nuestra situación
no se empalman o no se intersectan pues
no hay algún elemento que esté tanto en
b como en a por lo que en esta situación
la probabilidad de a&b es cero entonces
se va esta probabilidad y simplemente
queda la suma de probabilidades y estos
serían como eventos these juntos o
mutuamente excluyentes y si pasa esto si
son mutuamente excluyentes puedes decir
que la probabilidad de ave
la probabilidad de a v y listo